michelle obama calls for trump
you get kicked off and mark zuckerberg
says absolutely
michelle obama's statement is very wordy
as the obamas
are want to be you can read barack
obama's third memoir i think it's only
800 pages right now so i'll skip around
a little bit
obama talks about how she is so happy
that that radical socialist raphael
warnock won
election in georgia because he's going
to be georgia's first black senator
for socialist senator too i think then
first senator whoever hosted fidel
castro to church that's well
big wonderful history isn't it
then in just a few hours my heart had
fallen harder and faster than i can
remember
like all of you i watched as a gang
organized violent and mad
they'd lost an election laid siege to
the united states capital
oh terrible did she watch blm over the
summer not sure she did
oh no she did because she gets to it
later in her letter
this summer's black lives matter
protests were an
overwhelmingly peaceful movement oh my
gosh
our nation's largest demonstrations ever
bringing together people of every racing
class encouraging millions to re-examine
their own assumptions
and for those who call others
unpatriotic for simply taking a knee in
silent protest for those
who wonder why we need to be reminded
that black lives matter at all
you know nobody nobody needs to be
reminded of that yesterday
made it painfully clear that certain
americans are in fact allowed to
denigrate the flag and symbols of our
nation
they've just got to look the right way
so michelle obama also stoking all these
racial tensions which she did for her
entire public career as well
she makes the claim that black lives
matter is overwhelmingly peaceful
i guess i'm willing to grant that i mean
they did
torch cities coast to coast for a very
long time
but sure of the people who say that they
support black lives matter i suppose
it's a small percentage you get violent
right
and yet she says that here these trump
supporters
are violent thugs a gang
criminals she doesn't seem to
afford the trump supporters quite the
same grace that she affords to black
lives matter
even though just as a simple matter of
numbers
the trump supporters are much much much
much much incomparably more peaceful
than black lives matter has been
both in the riot even at the ride on the
capitol
compared to the torching of cities for
six months
but but also just more broadly blm
has come out they are a an explicitly
marxist organization
they say they want to disrupt the entire
society right down to including
the nuclear family and they have used
violence
repeatedly lots of blood on the hands of
blm
she won't afford them the same the same
grace
she won't afford trump trump supporters
the same grace and then she says
here's the key now is the time for those
who voted for this president to see the
reality of what they've supported and
publicly and forcefully
forcefully rebuke him and the actions of
that mob now is the time for silicon
valley companies to stop enabling this
monstrous behavior
and go even further than they have
already done
by permanently banning this man from
their platforms and putting in place
policies that prevent their technology
from being used
by this nation's leaders to fuel
insurrection insurrection
blm mostly peaceful protest the ride at
the capitol
insurrection which justifies the
censorship of the sitting president
himself
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts